a pandemic health concerns restrictions
on public spaces
you add it all up and the retail
association of nevada projects a bit of
a drop
quite a drop actually in brick and
mortar spending for the holiday shopping
season
hector mejia is live this afternoon with
more on the predictions from the
association pector
we usually see the outlets here in
downtown packed with
shoppers but this year analysts are
saying
they are predicting a slower 2020
holiday season here
specifically in nevada according to the
retail association of nevada our state's
brick and mortar sales could drop
anywhere between 3 percent and 8 percent
from last year
this forecast is only for holiday and
store sales
the economic factors used here we're
told include the uncertainty
surrounding covet 19 restrictions on top
of that nevada having the second highest
on the unemployment rate in the country
and governor steve sislac's latest
statewide pause which is in place for
the next
three weeks we expect nevadans
to tighten their belts much more
significantly
than the rest of the nation there are
about 127
000 more unemployed nevadans
this october than they were last october
obviously that puts a bit of a damper on
you know holiday shopping season people
have other things or they're
likely worried about
total non-store retail stores sales
rather however
grew significantly during the key
pandemic months
up a whopping 143 percent between
january and august compared to the same
period last year
that popularity and online shopping is
expected to hold
analysts are hoping those sales can help
fill in the gaps and it's estimated
that in a typical year the retail
industry contributes more than 1 billion
dollars
in annual tax revenue and also provides
more than 400 thousand jobs
across nevada reporting from downtown
hector mejia
8 news now